joining me now is Wesley Smith National
Review contributor and chairman of The
Discovery Institute Center on human
exceptionalism
Wesley you're the expert here
it seems at first glance that you know
less knight from this you know death
Cult of human extinction is kind of an
outlier
but his view really as at the is at the
core of so much of what the left has
come to believe today is it not yes and
I was really glad you made such a broad
uh so many broad examples of what we're
talking about because these are all
connected into a belief of human
unexceptionalism and it's extremely
unhealthy I mean we wonder why our
children are are having a suicide crisis
why there's so much depression drug
addiction and so forth when you have so
many people over so many different kinds
of issues pushing the idea that human
beings are wrong that we shouldn't be
here that there's something wrong with
us that paradise you know Paradise
without Adam and Eve would be better but
Paradise without Adam and Eve nobody
would know it was Paradise it's just
it's just really sad and it's really
nihilistic now more about this last
night character that the New York Times
profiled they describe him as tall and
gentle he comes across as a clear-eyed
and thought thoughtful like a mashup of
Bill Nye and Fred Rogers
while Mr Knight may be against the
creation of More Humans he shows great
compassion for the ones that already
exist a high school Substitute Teacher
Night is fondly regarded by students
Wesley this is uh I mean who you can't
pay for press like that from The New
York Times that's uh that's pretty good
you see this across issue after issue
where the mainstream media really does
push things like suicide parties
euthanasia dying on your own terms but
you know they haven't thought about the
dogs Laura if we're all dead who's going
to take care of the dogs the dogs need
us and love us so they're being very
cruel to animals right now how do you as
a political party which of course the
Democrats Embrace so many of these
ideals
push this idea that you want life better
on earth when so much of your you know
of your adherence actually believe that
life is the problem on Earth
you know that's a very interesting
question and why so many people seem to
be attracted to this I I think that
there is a sense of Despair and a sense
of hopelessness that's abounding in
society and what the transhumanists are
doing for example is a worship of
technology that is uh we're all going to
die oh no my gosh we're going to die so
we're going to have technology save us
and we're going to live forever by being
uploaded into a computer but if you're
uploaded into a computer you're not in
that computer there's a computer program
in that computer you're dead but it just
is a sense of you know if all we are is
carbon molecules what's the point and
that's where transhumanism comes in
that's where radical environmentalism
comes in which is becoming an earth
worship and the rejection of human
exceptionalism is something that drives
people crazy and we start eating our own
Tails now Wesley it is uh it is shocking
but this is The Logical conclusion this
is where it all ends up fewer people
fewer consumption less consumption and
less life Wesley thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else